ああああああ
ん
わーきましたお願いますすごいなこれ
この魚分かります何か
これ降りそうといいなんですよ
ねえねこれらの僕えっ4月にニューヨークに
一発でこれ世界で勝ってべく相場ライダーが集まって510台誘われました
でカナダでやっているてとカンファレンスをみんなで見るっていう
増えてますねじゃあそこでこの写真は僕バブもテッド x 月
デイパティ vr けどまぁ交流世界一あんですけど
マーフィーっ
60秒ですねも今日たまたま行為機会が
いただきましたので皆さんにちょっとお話をしたいと思います
ゴリ移動でもらえるかしてません
ながさきましたよねね
長崎なぜイエスができ後どれぽろさんすんぞ
ブーブーにょ
見てかかるんですね
でまぁ日本の中でも v って結構であー
取れるしいて養殖もあるんですけどももう本当に氷見のブリは大事にとって量も少ない
のでなかなかだけ
はい用意しそれちゃんといえばでブリって出世ようなんですね
ねえいくん不正をゲー
me
3 re na i テリアで後続なっています
ねえ小学生ぐらいのを決めると本堂
スタイルでそれからガンドポリ
いうふうに名前が変わります
で全国的に色の名前があっていい形案で興味がある人はちょっと自分で調べてみて
ください
いやーこんなことね言わんでもええトコ来い
あるんですけどねはい上から北陸で関東関西九州
そんな呼び方します
行為ですねしますねー
はい僕でも実は生まれは京都なんです
その後留学してアメリカに行っていついてしまいました
最初は大学の方で教えたんですけどもねあのー
帰国する直前はシリコンバレーで働いていました
これ何かわかります
これ自体消費税さん
キーボードあるようなを指紋センサーを作ってるベンチャーでと書かれていました
リーガーが僕ら向いてた会社なんですけども今はありません
2000年にドットコムバブルが8で当時
ジモンの世界の投球9針をざいました
ブーブーていると思ったら遊んぬ for iphone
についているやつです
数年前にアプリ買収さんってついています
太郎前を持ってますけどもスタン日にも
ああ
ちょっとねぇ者思うんですけど
でもそれからもうビザも取れなくなったので帰ってきました
それは別に今晩いいたのに僕いきなりトラクターに乗ってるんですよ
10小企業向けの高ブルドブランディというのでもう十分年前でやりました
早すぎますよねそんなね網膜行かないですんでも真ん中はねえインドに一定通りの痔
ねーー市に青鬼を連れてきて
生活スタイルを教えて発見するというビジネスやっていました
なんかちょっとしてしまうとまぁちょっとした成功とたくさんの失敗をしてねそのたび
に東京のほうに行って働いていました
でまぁ入ってすぐに今度リーマンショックが来たのでまず1年でクビですよもういいか
もないまた帰ってきました
僕はの強度なんですけども待つ間とアメリカで出会ったので端うしっかの北陸の方に
入りました
これ日々なんですけどもブーブー足の横
ねっなんですよすごい pros よねこれこっちブーブリオ黒線にょする
外で食べてますポニー日本で唯一恋 g が持っている
50そうですよこれはつまりびっくりまぁこれでもうね久しぶり切り端たんですけどね
車で通ってるのわかんないですね
でも走ってズキズキましょブリアン系ってねぇー
ブーブー秒黄色サティ
鉄骨けれど全然ボウタイみたいなねまあホールの栗
ね地域商品券も古い
これからからね魚の遊具なんですけどこれを競ってクリアと思います
後ろに癖がありますよねはいこれもぶりだ
これもぶりです横に持っています姉御坊ツンっていいんですけどこれ作者すごいです
藤子不二雄a 先生です
動いで疲れて切り生まれなんですこれぶりこれも彼のキャラクターですね
左側 shun at してるじゃないですかこれ無理とプリーツ上手 bully
作っています
これすごいですよ手を振りコートまでいます
どんな風に突き上げてねっ
とだから猫クリックの魚ってねまあああいうヒットや髪が美味しいと言うじゃないです
か
無理じゃあ速にこの魚が美味しいえるって
なんかヒーローございさ
ねぇいくつあります
冷たい海水で脂がのってるねーー
言うじゃないですか
波にもまれて身が締まってるっていうことですねっ
あとこれへ立山連峰の栄養を含んだユズるって言うから
弓間
聞くでしょねぇ
を全部で嘘なんですよ
本当にで僕もいいミク場ででしょ
ねぇねぇあの東京に行ったときにも全然
首に行って願いして帰ってきたら肉もなければいいな観光協会があったんで
神の観光協会に入ったですね j 君はブーン生かしたからだし
まあ軽い気持ちでリング虚構に行ったらその時のトップの日聞かれました
ッパでございましたよ
これですよドライバーで打ってしまいましたがここで全部間違ってませ品なのねー
だってこんなのテレビで見たら信じるじゃないですか
ネオマジでしやーねーテレビの方が来られるとちゃんとお話をしてこれ俺
違うんですよっていう話じゃね
じゃあ v は何で違うんですかって言う
はいこれグリーンなんですけど体ジャンルで撮ってるでしょとっている持って北海道
ui が見えざり阿部食べるんですよ
なんでですか立っ
ねえか言うでしょで九州で産卵するじゃないですか北海道からおいでもらったんでしょ
その泳いでくれに食べて飲んでるんですねあと何そっと清掃にも入れる日が前非
だって鮭がて彼は思って見て産卵した美術館スターでしょ
一緒なんですよ v だってから北海道にいるときは一番を振っているだけになって
乱打したときに頭いい意味でかかっ
てミーナ冷たいアイスいやから脂が乗ってる人と大嘘ですよね国会と理由からみれさん
を食べてしっかりと身が脂がのってる
寝ていたので優しく取るから牛と
なんだよ国名は低チャンミンがしない広めなかなと思って
帝ちゃんに枝張りる人ってその各4でゆっくりにょてみましたこの人もっとアップルの
アップ age る人っています
it のパティ予定だピョンへ一暑いしました
さてもう谷駅
国営放送局から来ましたでオンエアで5分待ってましたよ
歓迎されないとなりしましたチョンビョンマン中にするとこれでいきましょう
ん
見てました
これでした1
何ですかこれはああああ
これですよ型チャーム行く脚普通ですか売れ
なあまあ頑張ってねあの
くじけるに今一生懸命やってます
いやおかげで貼ってで撮ったデックスでしゃべる機会をいただきました
はい
特価でテレビ様子見たこそ大事じゃないですかそう
上から見たらこんな感じになります gree 空間出るんですよ
洗って1位なんですね魚が入って出てくるからそのままだけど大きさながらが分から
ないですよねちょっと比較珍妙所
これまあ上から見た感じですよねー
で体ちゃうって答えてみると思うねここにねこう
ロープがバーンってですねそれだけだったら僕らんでしょ
でも一番端っこにねう気が付いてるんですよね大きいの先に
にょどれぐだけどこれますぜ
横にあるでしょう無難かね僕の彼女こじまるくらいあるんだですこれでバーンと入って
います
はい
いや後でデイ者でどれくらいでばいいんですか
これ
豪華結成ねえだいたい長坂300メーター
高さが7自分じゃないけどこいつはねぇ
ふっを得られます
無茶苦茶でかいいですよ僕の市茶屋常長入って言葉泳ぎましたけどまぁ見えないですよ
ね
なのでれていた見上げる時にはもう左パンの2つのとこだけしかかけません
じゃあもうちょっと方がいい比べてみましょう何でつけないでしょ
これはありますよねつい不良ようなねやっぱりこうフォークですよ
あこいつ高さ18.4メーターありますこれがねだいたい先っぽのところでで3ついい
ぐらいですよ
ブーブーん
8ねいいよくっ
と眠るよねこうくる著この上から車輪伸びている
ありがありますここ年水が流れるんで音が聞こえるんですよ
やっぱり音が聞こえたらねだいたい銃砲メーターぐらいまでどうぞなんか聞こえん
なんか小沢ないっつって動物の高層本部で逃げようとします
ということはこれてまりはリップで上が大きなですがお気に入り減速比ね
こう言うでしょうねです彼と思う
でそこにちゃん持っていたりが大待っている
よくできてるんです
こういうふうに入って言って僕に行ってみよう所でそのままでもうこれに歌ってるじゃ
ないですか
もう逃げ放題ですよこれい
見えますはいどれぐらいに見えると思います
良く言っ
八幡に入れます
もうのすごい効率悪いですねなんでもいいんじゃないですよねハ第2分だもそんなんで
それでもね言うでしょねこれで言ってるんですよ
天の恵みのおこぼれを怒ら
程度ビラビラです2割しかとれないからをこれでいいでしょ
それくらい自然と共存しているえってぃーちゃんなんですけどねこれ世界を救うかも
しれん
日本人大別と者横目取った後はラナーの思いましたね
こういう自然素材を使って日本が私は漁業をしていました
花伸ばしたのかのーあんだなバラなぁなんでしょ
で浮きなんかは
妄想だけになりますねね下の行もうなんかは
麻縄でやりますでこれあ無理かもって言ったらね僕いいジャガーってペアまで長骨
アフリカの[ __ ]日本のゴールなハイブリッドで出来てる奴なんですけども
このコメがコシヒカリの3倍とるんですよ
ラン振り返って環境が良いから日本作3毛作可能なんですね
第1話れてるんですけども安座間これからチャンス余地があります
[音楽]
ブーバやんっていうとマティ
だから山と海の里山里海のハブになっているのが地下定着なんですね
そう豊かなライフエコサイクル僕らの具10年前にはあったんですよ
この停滞に未だに日本映画んでやってますみなさんもうこんな実はあったんだなあって
いうのを
おいてくださいねこれはアフリカの人たちじゃあ毎日でやってもらっています
はい sdg もちゃんときますこれどう魚と体がダメなのかっていうのがアプリで
ありますこれクリダメってなってますけど
待って予定ちゃんこれ ok や金の僕は言いたいかという
最後にあとちょっと寿司世界子ですよねー
やさしいて介護ですよねこの次に僕は
低ちゃんっていうのを世界標準にしたいと思います
ディカプリオいるでしょ映画のかの人を
リムジンに乗って次の年早売りと思ったじゃないですか
世界でそこましたでしょね彼数年前国連の身売りで海洋資源の保護のスピーチしてるん
です
ということは彼のではもう海へ向かっているんですね
彼が僕の泥 jal でかかるのはものすげえとが出るでフェア
はいみなさんも一緒に広島で水挿し入っていている
行くぞ数字さしーいーんじゃあねありがとうござい
[拍手]